housemd actually does clinic hours let's
see some of his wildest encounters huge
thank you to headspace for sponsoring a
part of today's video
my asthma
they said they'd fix it but it didn't
make any difference at all asthma step
up plan if you're using your rescue
inhaler too often aka your albuterol you
might need a controller medication to
prevent asthma attacks from happening
some people have specific triggers that
they can avoid or they can take
medicines targeting those triggers you
like to think about allergy medicines
for that you could take your traditional
antihistamines or maybe even a
medication like singular gotta think
outside the box with asthma you're using
your inhaler all the time go through one
a week
you sure you're using it right a lot of
patients especially children tend to not
use it correctly because they weren't
properly educated they would benefit
from a spacer this is what a spacer
looks like
come on there's images on the bottle of
what you're supposed to do that's never
gonna happen experiencing fatigue and
weakness usually he's stronger than ox
102 year old ox
102 year old ox and elderly ox he's
tingling in his feet in his legs i want
a full battery of tests well maybe we
want to check if he's diabetic because
in that case you could treat that and
you could change quality of life
tremendously it's nice of you to float
your friend he's not my friend he's my
father he's 22 years older than me well
that's true he's definitely had his
jowls done
statistically if he didn't have these
symptoms he'd be like most people of his
age dead for the past several decades do
the tests i'm sick you have a bad case
of natural causes first of all he should
do some things but i wonder what they
think it is that's like one of the first
questions i ask as a doctor he's 102.
his next test is an autopsy look i i
love the old man but i got to get him
out of the damn house he needs to be
in a care facility so tell him he's a
big boy now
that's very generous when you were 30.
[Music]
pretend to run the tests we don't do
that you can't bribe doctors to give you
the results that you want doctors really
shouldn't be accepting gifts i think
it's over 30 i think that's what our
tests say when a patient bakes you a
cake it's fine but if a patient bakes
you a cake with gold flakes on it you
have to say no i love him but he can't
let go
40 bucks says he can i can't do anything
without him helping me like i'm senile
he's gonna give him five bucks
how do i give a hug skip the blood work
tell my son it's grim news i need to be
in a nursing home i think that's
actually a dis if a patient thinks they
can buy you that means you're sending
off the wrong signals and if two
patients
think they can buy you that means you
probably should be retiring test results
is my recommendation that you move into
a home with round-the-clock care i can't
believe it
can't my son give me around the clock
here not unless you've done your
two-year certification in tipiron's swab
technology tip you're on what technology
it's made up just because he has a
little tingling and some trouble feeling
hot and cold that's the spinal oh my god
the phthalic pathway of the spine god i
don't remember the pathways anymore show
me your denture cream he has
zinc poisoning
to get it from denture cream you have to
take so much of it trust me he never
leaves home without it how much do you
use pop
about a tube a day which explains all
your symptoms medically there's no
reason to go anywhere he solved the case
that the patients didn't want solved
back to the show in just a second but
first i want to thank headspace for
sponsoring this part of the video my
life is pretty chaotic whether i'm
treating patients in the hospital making
youtube videos training as a boxer or
taking care of bear my attention is
constantly being tugged in multiple
directions i'm sure many of you feel the
same way which is why i would recommend
you try out headspace an app you can use
every day to build good habits that
improve your mental well-being they have
over a thousand pieces of premium
content where you can find any resource
for any mood or any goal that you want
to achieve there are guided meditations
eyes open exercises like mindful walks
and runs breathing exercises sleep
content focus playlists and so much more
there's really something for everyone
from guided meditations for beginners to
less structured programming for more
seasoned individuals a wide variety of
meditation teachers offer their unique
perspectives as well so you can try a
bunch out to see what's right for you
not only have these mindfulness
techniques been used for thousands of
years but science has backed them up as
well proving that regularly engaging in
mindfulness exercises can lead to a
happier and healthier life sign up today
for a free trial and thanks again to
headspace for sponsoring this part of
the video let's get back to the show
you're not pregnant
well i told you that
you were pregnant
based on your hormone levels you've had
a miscarriage well that could happen we
can see that yeah i haven't even been on
a date right
since it's physically impossible to have
sex without someone buying you dinner i
haven't had sex fine have it your way
immaculate conception or
how about this dr house the patient has
a tumor that's secreting the hormone
that you think is responsible for her
lost pregnancy and you think about her
cancer potential diagnosis instead of
assuming she's a liar what do i do
well it's obvious
to start a religion
take birth control if you truly believe
that she was pregnant as a result of
sexual activity it's got your results
back no ghb no nothing
means you're having sex and you're lying
about it no i haven't had any in over a
year i just wake up really exhausted oh
my god is she sleepwalking my ex lives
in the apartment downstairs
he's always calling me always wanting to
get back together complaining about
mixed signals we have a sleep lab in the
basement
nothing else i'll get you away from your
ex for a night see when i send patients
with sleep lab it's usually to diagnose
sleep apnea which is basically where you
stop breathing for a period of time and
as a result you wake up and you're not
really able to get good quality sleep
and as a result you get increased risk
of all these other conditions like
hypertension cardiac disease even
diabetes in some cases these were your
brain waves at 2 45 am
here it comes is an abrupt jump from
slow wave sleeping this indicates
partial sleep arousal
most common type is subnamebilism
sleepwalking that would explain why i'm
so tired when i wake up yes and also why
you were pregnant
i had sex
in my sleep only in a medical drama
no formula just mommy's healthy natural
breast milk i hope you also supplement
with vitamin d 400 iu or 10 micrograms
her whole face just got swollen like
this overnight
maybe a little slap cheek a little parvo
virus b19 no
fever
blends normal did he did he go
glands normal my guy feel the cleanse
vaccination dates we're not vaccinating
house please handle this with some
empathy please empathetic approach think
they don't work i think some
multinational pharmaceutical company
wants me to think they work pad their
bottom line you know another really good
business
teeny tiny baby kong
she has a menstrual cup
they're really bad the pain keeps her in
bed all day plus she's super depressed a
red nose could be a sign of a viral
illness perhaps allergies frequent
rubbing also patient looks a little bit
pale heavy menses with menstrual pain
could be related to fibroids she wants
birth control pills for her pms i guess
or is she pregnant judging by the
redness around your mom's nostrils and
the tissue she's got conveniently
stashed in her wristband i'd say her
problem is more likely a uri a uri upper
respiratory infection i'll have a
respiratory infection i also think she's
got a problem with sac sac stupid
american child if you want the pill
all you have to do is to walk into any
health clinic in jersey alone and ask
for it how in the world did he know this
i would rack my brain for days trying to
help the patient he just assumes the
worst how do you even function this way
is that for a cold no that's for your
ovaries i assume you haven't had a
stroke have you ever had a blood clot no
super also ask if she smokes dr house
that's important i know i'm taking the
decongestants but she's not getting
better she also says what
her boobs are bigger is she taking the
birth control how could you get them
mixed up
they come in a little wheel they don't
look anything like decongestants
no you gave her the wrong pills
you speak mandarin what is happening in
this episode he speaks every language he
knows every body part he knows every
snake poison and rat toe
so when did this start
a couple weeks ago i didn't want to get
pregnant jake's not into rubbers so i
got on the jelly
you have an infection i'm gonna need a
sample i brought the jar wait she
literally is putting jelly okay
we have a neurological problem here
there's something wrong with my brain
oh yeah
okay i'm gonna give you some antibiotics
and you probably shouldn't have sex for
a while how long
on an evolutionary basis i'd recommend
forever
so mean i think it goes without saying
but strawberry jelly is not a birth
control option never thought i'd say
that on this channel but it's not
i ranked every medical drama see where
house md falls on the list and as always
stay happy and healthy it's important i
said it